.
- On nous a forcé à apprendre
nous rejetait.
- "Pour toi Flora" est
une série troublante et vraie.
autochtones étaient visiblement
émus après avoir vu les deu
premiers épisodes.
- Je suis fier d'être Ashi
(applaudissements)NE MICHEL, sue
des pensionnats autochtones
m'a vraiment touché dans
le fond. T'sais, c'est venu
me chercher à l'intérieur.
j'ai choisi de raconter
notre histoire.de deux enfants e
enlevés en 1960 et placés
dans un pensionnat autochtone
de l'Abitibi-Témiscamingue.
Cette fiction a été écrite et
Sonia Bonspille Boileau.
SONIA BONSPILLE BOILEAU, réal.
et scénariste, "Pour toi Flora"
de "Pour toi Flora", en fait,
ça vient de ma famille. Moi,
mon grand-père et toutes
ses soeurs sont allés dansup
affecté ma famille, toutes
mes questions identitaires
quand je grandissais.sé s'efface
que tu as décidé d'en parler
dans le livre!
- Inspirée de divers
en scène Rémi et Flora, qui
ère et soère et soère et soère .
Ils revisitent cette enfance
qu'on leur a volée.
dans "Pour toi Flora"
- Rémi choisit la
Flora est dans le mensonge.
Donc, on peut pas demander
à Floraendu Rémi.
Et, à un moment donné dans la
série, ine rencontre
entre Rémi et Flora.
- Ton premier matin dans ce
bâtiment bizarre...re
le passé et le présent, le tour
de force de cette de
mettre le doigt sur les préjugés
encore bien présents dans
les soup
- Moi, je me suis dit, je neme e
je vais mettre, dans tout ce
que j'ai entendu comme préjugé.
ça existe, je l'entends,
j'en suis consciente.
aussi question du rôle joué
par l'Église. André Robit
incarne le père Bédard,
un personnage complexe.
ANDRÉ ROBITAILL
- Pourquoi j'ai dit oui?
Parce qu'est là'est là'est là'eà
que vous mettez une musique...
zoom in..., ça va être
prétenci
de changer le monde à coups
d'ailes de papillons, c'est sûr.
disponible en ligne sur l'extra
d'ICI TOU.TV dès ce jeudi.
Une série essentielle et qui
nous met face à notre ignor
- Espérons que ça va envoyer
le message pour savoir comme
MADELEINE BASILE, survivante
des pensionnats autochtones
- Ce qui est important,
e, l'histoire des
pensionnats indiens au Canada.a,
je te demande pardon...
- Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
ntréal.
♪ ♪